what made you once a day and go freaky
freaky with everyone
[Music]
okay yes so this is a video where
they're basically teaching kids about
polyamory
and monogamy and a lot of people are
really upset with jubilee
for kind of showcasing this kind of
relationship stuff to kids
so we're going to take a look at the
video and tell your thoughts
so today i'm going to talk to you about
polyamory have you ever heard about that
before
no probably everything it's
where you like have either two
boyfriends or two girlfriends like that
or you have more
yeah that's pretty much it even if i
have a boyfriend or a girlfriend
that i'm open to the possibility of
connecting with
somebody else what that husband or dad
husband
i don't get it like an example i like to
give when i talk about polyamory is
do you have a favorite food i like pizza
a lot i can't decide
you can't decide perfect example right
give me your top
three favorite foods can i give
restaurants sure yeah
in and out chipotle and um
chili's okay awesome polyamory is saying
great it's amazing that you love all of
those restaurants and you probably love
them
for all like different reasons right
whereas monogamy's like you can only eat
in and out for the rest of your life and
you can never have another restaurant
again
i like that my whole point is a
relationship is much more complex
and much more give and take than that to
just take it as something that you're
going to consume
already frames relationship in a very
selfish way what do you want to eat you
want to eat apples today you want to eat
oranges well eat them both
as different people eats you as well
exactly because the apple eats you
it's not it's it's it's it's a symbiotic
relationship but then it's something
you're sharing with somebody else
and that you're giving and you're so so
i i just think it's a weird way to frame
what's your favorite food do you want to
eat this and this well you can have both
of course it sounds appealing
yeah of course i see what you're saying
you're not talking about the cost of
having to give
or the reward of giving the reward of
loving so for me
just the way that they're framing it and
explaining to me stupid yeah
yeah i agree with you so if this is
going to be an educational video it's
the worst one to show your kids
because it doesn't reflect it but then
again if you eat fast food the fast food
will consume you eventually
even though it's just food it's food it
doesn't either have feelings
i feel like this girl knows this your
life skin kid
maybe you're at school and you want to
play with your best friend but then
maybe
the next day somebody who you've never
played with before invites you
over to the swing set your best friend
she might be jealous
but that doesn't mean that you don't
love her anymore that you don't want to
play with her ever again
i was really going with this and i was
like yeah alfred and the more she talks
the more
she gives examples the more i'm like so
uh how do you make babies uh it's really
it's when the dad
loves the mom really really really
really much
and then a kid comes out hey you missed
a lot of steps there
i'm just i'm just glad that my parents
you know my parents went in
like they were supposed to go in i'm
just glad my mom just never said
anything and i googled everything
you ain't [ __ ] for that one wow
man do you know how bad my education was
yeah
man the stories and i don't imagine your
mom talking about that and saying
what what is sex
who gives you kids a lot
but what if he ends up catching more
feelings for her than you
yeah you're not good for me anymore me
and susie who i met last night which you
allowed me to date
yeah we're leaving [ __ ] like this
let's get this done let's get yeah me
and susie i think he's just a [ __ ]
disturber
i ain't mad at his giving me vibes like
i'm smart and i'm gonna let you know
cause i'm gonna [ __ ] with you
okay so i like this uh yeah it happened
to me so i'm just gonna leave your ass
on the curb
what about that look i don't trust any
kid that looks like he's about to go
disco all right bye
that's absolutely a possibility
everybody is allowed to
follow their heart in whatever way makes
sense to them so even though it would be
painful that my partner might have
stronger feelings for somebody else i
would
want them to do whatever made them
happiest
what made you once a day and go freaky
freaky with everyone
[Laughter]
freaky freaky i told you i never trust
kids who look like they're about to
disco
say you were to get pregnant how would
you know who the father was
um because you're seeing all these men
how could you keep
track would you just go to boyfriend
number one
are you the father take the dna test
nope okay boyfriend number sixty nine
thousand four hundred and two wow
this is just low-key roasted her loki
boyfriend 69 702 000.
20. are you the boy no okay
well that's all of them well for me
personally if i'm going to get pregnant
it's going to be a very
intentional purposeful thing and at that
point i would probably just want to
focus on the one person that i would
want to have a family with
all right hello hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
i'm evan nice to meet you
hello evan so how um how has been going
today like do you have any thoughts on
kind of like
monogamy or polyamory i am leaning on
the other side on
being free to choose
and to have many partners free to choose
why why do you say that because you just
don't want to lock yourself
up with one person and say bam that's
your wife great
now don't do anything else you must only
love her and you must
he just want stuff he's just one man he
just wants to mess with
that's he's a [ __ ] disturbing yeah i am
man i see myself
you my friend he [ __ ] it up and he
leaves and he must only be
with her forever that is intense
do you have a favorite
disney princess yes who is it
man see this is why jubilee's a [ __ ]
channel between the cut
and all these other like the way they
cast this [ __ ] is just
hot garbage who are they getting these
people to explain these concepts
do you have like a best friend do you
want to be that best friend forever for
like
my girlfriend is not even my best friend
and i'm not my girlfriend's best friend
and sometimes you have multiple best
friends
anyway yes you do and that's my girl
girl
i have lots of them like cinderella
ariel
though and they all have just one prince
just one prince yeah and that's kind of
what like
makes it so amazing is that like you
literally said nothing
you explained nothing there was no
concept
that was vapid there was nothing
bro there was there was there was
actually there was
nothing nothing
[Music]
i'm super mad
i'm done how many girls have you dated
and how many
um times have you watched netflix and
killed with them
um this my dude this is my dude
he's getting spicy give my homie his own
channel he getting spicy
he can't spicy he has own size drama
alert i think he has own channel
yeah that's it do you like see these
just in movies and that's why you decide
to be monogamous or do you decide on
your own decision
that's a really great question there is
something about
having like one singular partner one
person you can truly depend on
that actually kind of help like
simplifies everything because
it's about that stability and about that
person who you know
no matter what happens in your life that
they will be there for you you didn't
answer a question
everyone give one you didn't answer a
question
you did not answer her question that was
not her question that's not what she
said
so not only that you're explaining stuff
in a way that
there's no sense to it but when she's
asking you a question you don't answer
the question
are you with one
girlfriend no because you know like my
girlfriend's my princess and just like
beast never gets bored of belle i never
get bored of my girlfriend
how do you explain divorces then so once
you have this girlfriend
are you cool with like her having
another boyfriend
uh-huh that's not good shoe school with
me having another girl
oh man this guy is woefully unprepared
for this
you would feel jealous if she was like
kissing another dude well as long as she
doesn't feel jealous that i'm kissing
another girl
but i have to ask you a question sure if
melody is
so great then how come the divorce rates
are
so high that's a really why are people
getting married just to say you know
it's over i don't want to be with you
anymore take
take the dog okay i'm taking my son
i actually think that's a really great
question but like i think it's usually
way more complicated than that and
looking at people who have been
divorced like it's not just because
someone like wants another
partner there's like a lot of reasons
why people might get divorced really
yes is it really oh for sure well
what's your favorite food i don't have a
favorite food man i'm gonna flip it on
you
i'ma flip it on you he flipped it he cuz
he said nothing yeah no
it's a complicated we feel whack man i'm
done i'm going on my phone i don't see
why man just
[ __ ] jubilee don't take this as he
hate it's just like
you guys have opportunities to to make
interesting content the thing is
and the concepts aren't terrible but you
execute it so
terrible i don't know why you cast these
people who are not prepared it was like
when you cast that intel dude in the
mra versus you just you keep casting
weird people
and it's just like you have you have the
means to do it
i mean this was clearly done in social
distancing there was there was like a
plexiglass between y'all
you have the means the setup the place
you have all this
the power to do all this great stuff
and that's that's what that's what you
do
you put this out i'm shocked you watch
the final edit and you put it up i'm
assuming you put it out for money
because this is close to i wouldn't say
misinformation but this certainly
doesn't
just identify at the end of the day
whether it's good comments or bad
comments if people are viewing it
they're they're gonna get they're gonna
get what they need to get no because
they have a mission we have a goal
while apparently it's not just making
money well
i mean from what i see i don't know how
you guys watched and thought that was a
good video
i'm really blown away genuinely blown
away hey i was about to give you a
chance you
but but not now you'll fail again so
that's it for today's video can we can
we stop watching jubilee videos can we
do that
no because it makes us money and um
that's what i'm in it for
[Music]
that's my trick i am at it
oh wow you got a problem no not with us
watching the video it's just
it's i'm just going back to that and i'm
like oh yeah just
oh you like how do you have all this
look look at this
listen don't look at this look around i
don't i don't even know when is an
appropriate time to have this kind of
discussion with your children or what
age or
you know if you should answer it when
your kids i think every parent has to
decide that for themselves
i think there is a worthwhile point and
merit to
having that conversation with your kids
when they're fairly young or young
enough because
kids are having these conversations on
their own and sometimes engaging in
these acts on their own without your
knowing as a parent
without any without you ever telling
them anything so
better you have that conversation with
them and that you you
educate them then some other that's the
number that jubilee than some other
person talking about
instances and freaking fast food so
so i think there's merits out but you
know we want to hear your thoughts would
you have this conversation with your
children
and tell us what you thought about the
jubilee video we want to hear your
comments below
[Music]